what up space fame goes in here from
anime upper and i'm back with another
demonstrator video a demon series video
is definitely overdue so here we are the
latest edition of the how strong is
every hashira series this one covers the
eccentric tangent uzui the sound pillar
himself again the most important pillar
in the upcoming new season i think
mitsuri and shinobu may be the only hush
i haven't covered yet so let me know
which one you'd rather see next in the
comments and if we can get 4 000 likes i
repeat 4 000 color changing thumbs i'll
get started on the next one asap if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and while you wait
for the next demonstrator video to drop
feel free to check out my huge and
growing demonstrator playlist that
includes videos about all the hashira
demon moons and much more link to that
is in the description now without
further ado let's jump into it spoilers
and all so let's turn to the ultra cool
23 year old sound pillar whose birthday
is october 31st making him october's
very own like me he's physically very
strong and in an arm wrestling contest
among the pillars tangent ranked second
only behind the gentle giant earth
pillar gyome as we know though overall
fighting prowess is not just about
physical strength especially in shonen
so we'll break down in detail tengen's
abilities and see where he actually
stands among the other characters in the
series and among the hashira in
particular obviously among all demon
slayers tengen is one of the best which
is why he's one of the pillars aka the
highest ranking combatants of the
demonstr when he was introduced he
wasn't as likable as he'd later become
especially because he talked about
cutting her precious nezuko's head off
flamboyantly and how he could make the
blood spray more flamboyantly than
anyone else obviously sonomy the wind
pillar still beat him in the worst first
impressions department by actually
hurting nezuko but tengen was also one
of the ones flamboyantly opposed to
accepting nezuko and said he could never
accept a demon hunter who brings demons
along as the sound pillar he obviously
was a practitioner of sound breathing
and to his credit he created this
explosive combat style himself notably
he also has a ninja background and
wields dual giant nichiren cleavers
rather than one normal sword he ends up
being relevant to the story when he is
carrying off aoi and another butterfly
estate girl against their will so they
can assist him on a mission tanjo helps
put a stop to it tundra uses headbutt
expecting it to be super effective but
to tengan's credit he's quick enough to
avoid it in fact he's so fast it looks
like he teleported to a nearby roof
tanjori nosuke and zanitsu managed to
convince him not to take aoi by offering
themselves to go in her stead and
finally tangent agrees to these terms so
far he's wanted to kill nezuko and tried
kidnapping butterfly state girls against
their will while demonstrating his
insane speed again he's clearly not good
at first or even second impressions as
he tells our demon sayers that he is god
and they are trash and must do whatever
he says i do love how when he calls
himself the god of festivities instead
of thinking he's a [ __ ] like zanito
does inosuke says he's the king of the
mountain and it's nice for the king of
the mountain to meet the god of
festivities you gotta love enosuke
anyways as they head to the
entertainment district the three
demonstrator amigos are left in awe at
tangent speed once again it looks like
he vanishes before their eyes and the
next thing they know they see him so far
away he looks as small as a seed in the
distance clearly even among the pillars
the manga is emphasizing that tangent
excels in speed we find out that tangent
wants to look for his wife and for info
on a demon as well as if this didn't
make zany too jealous enough tengan goes
on to reveal that he actually has three
wives who are top of the line female
ninja in their own right tengen makes
the others dress as girls as they go
undercover and ferret out the upper moon
he's looking for when inosuke and tundra
meet up tengen shows up suddenly
catching them completely off guard which
goes with the idea of him being a ninja
inosuke thinks that it's impressive how
tangen never made a sound when he was
showing up and the wind never even
swayed it's like he's a more flamboyant
batman on a more serious note tengen
mentions that he hasn't heard from
zanitsu and that he made a mistake
bringing them here they're too low
ranking and this demon is an upper moon
so he tells them that he'll move on his
own so clearly either has confidence
that he has a chance against an upper
moon alone or at least is brave enough
to try in any case both possibilities
speak to his character we soon see how
good tengan is at using sound to figure
out exactly what's going on from a
distance not only does he realize that a
battle is going on underground by
listening by reading the reverberations
he is able to tell that there's a huge
cave underground and that the tunnels
that lead to it are so narrow that only
little kids could get through at this
point tangy and his weapons are hyped up
we're told he wields two swords and
these swords have an unbelievable
explosive strength nobody knows how they
work for those who have received a blow
from them have never survived
end quote that's definitely a hype
description from the narrator that
should not be under emphasized but it
also begs the question how strong were
tangents previous opponents probably not
upper moon level so this fight between
upper moon and undefeated pillar is
being set up as quite the hype match-up
tengen's entrance is no less hype he
couldn't actually fit into tunnels so
that he could get to the fighting arena
where inosuke and zenitsu were fighting
daki's sash a part of her ability lets
her create these detached living flesh
sashes and she made the flesh sashes
guard her captured victims so what does
tengen do he creates an explosion from
above ground big enough so he could drop
into the scene like a boss the sash is
shocked that someone managed to open a
hole from above ground then we start
seeing tangent in action in a way we
haven't seen up to this point the sash
can immediately tell by his presence
that he's a pillar it's very high praise
when the enemy can sense that you're at
such a high level that there's no way
you haven't been promoted to the top
level of the demonstra core inosuke and
zenitsu were struggling with the sashes
but tangent is a different story slicing
the sashes countless times in a very
small time frame so there's no way you
can actually keep up with his speed
visually he succeeds in rescuing
everyone and as hinosuke puts it the
maggot sashes run away disappearing into
the holes clearly not feeling like there
was a point in facing someone of
tangent's caliber when tangent gives
chase again inosuke can't help but
remark how fast tengen is the sash is
returned to daki and she realizes what
they've experienced and that a pillar is
present however she's not worried
feeling that it'll work out showing that
even to upper moon 6 the lowest ranking
upper moon there isn't a fear around
pillars while tanjiro and nezuko are
fighting doki nezuko enters her mature
form and starts losing it when tangent
shows up suddenly he mentions that
nezuko's flamboyantly progressing into a
demon pretty hilarious thing to say in
such an intense situation and then we
get a big flex from tengen he lets us
know that doki isn't even an upper moon
or at least not on her own as we find
out later tangent can immediately sense
that she's too weak and she is not the
upper moon he was looking for tengen
cuts her head off in a moment using his
speed before she or we the readers fully
understand what's going on again
combining so much physical strength and
speed is pretty amazing as we witness
him effortlessly take out a demon that
was giving tanjiro and
pre-transformation nezuko a lot of
trouble tengen's deduction skills were
correct and eventually yutaro daki's
brother emerges from her body and he's
clearly the stronger of the two upper
moon sixes even tengen fails to hit him
with his attack and remarks that
gootaro's reaction speed is no laughing
matter coming from him that's a big deal
to tangent's credit the pillar manages
to stop gyutaro's first attack even
though he had intention to kill behind
the attack it's worth mentioning that
gyutaro who's not very pretty has
immense envy when he sees the over six
foot tall attractive ladies man in front
of him the fact that tangent has three
wives bothers guterre like he was
running to himself guterre launches his
bloodsickle attack at tengen and the
blades of blood look like they're gonna
be a problem until tangent uses his
explosion ability to escape to another
floor we also see tiny bombs at this
point that tangent releases and cuts to
cause the explosions that accompany his
explosive combat style a very
interesting style for a swordsman to
adopt and very unique among any other
demon slayers we've seen gyutaro gives
tengen more praise after fighting him
for a while saying he's different from
all the pillars he's killed up to now he
assumes that tangent was a special guy
from birth who got chosen by talent and
this is where tangan despite all the
hyping up of his character reveals that
he's not so special among the pillars he
remarks that gyutaro must have had a
wonderful life if he thinks someone like
tangen has talent for tangent people
like muichiro and gyome are the talented
ones definitely not him at this point
gyutaro reveals that not only can he
control his airborne bloodblades like
homing missiles they are also full of
deadly poison so he's shocked that
tengen hasn't dropped dead at this point
we find out another strength of tangents
because he's from a ninja family he's
actually developed some resistance to
poison it's also revealed that tengan
grew up in a family where his father
forced him to train intensely and he was
one of only two of his nine siblings who
survived tangent goes on to hold his own
against gyutaro and daki until the three
demon-slaying amigos arrive but it's
significant that the poison though not
killing him yet is working slow and
steady and so we gotta keep in mind that
this fight will include tangent far from
prime condition and i say that while
also noting that he failed to kill the
two demons before he was heavily
poisoned as well another significant
detail that's revealed over the course
of the fight is that gyutaro has already
eaten 15 pillars and daki has eaten
seven so right away if tangent comes out
of this alive it's impressive in and of
itself then the battle resumes and
yutaro goes after tanjiro but tundra is
saved by tengen's speed and pulled to
safety tundra admits that he was holding
tengen back by forcing the ladder to
protect him tundra soon repays the favor
though and while tangent thinks it's too
late to avoid some blood blades tundra
manages to use some water breathing to
deflect the attacks they work together
and even a wife of tangents helps by
launching kunai at yutaro at this point
tangent has an amazing moment where he
gets close to utero and even with kunai
hitting him he maintains his focus and
thanks to his ninja training doesn't
even flinch from the multiple kunai hits
he manages to distract yutaro dodge an
attack of his and then akunai hits a
distracted yutaro while tangent cuts the
demon's legs it was an amazingly
executed combo since the kunai was laced
with wisteria flowers gyutaro doesn't
regenerate right away his body goes numb
however the upper moon is too powerful
and a poison that would affect an
unnumbered demon for half a day stops
affecting yutaro pretty soon as his leg
regenerates in this way he catches
tundra and tangent off guard but tengen
has the ability to kick tundra to safety
before he dies he also uses sound breath
forth form death nails of avicii to
block yutaro's countless blood blades
yutaro though takes tengan's wife
hostage and as he does tangent gets a
flashback of her saying and i quote once
we defeat an upper moon let's retreat
from the front lines end quote so
clearly retirement is something that was
on tangent's mind even before this fight
thanks to his wives tundra ends up being
the one to save her to giutaro's
surprise even a combined attack though
doesn't stop yutaro in fact he even
manages to rescue doki's head from
inosuke by stabbing him with his
poisoned sickle in the meantime tanjiro
sees that tangen is on the ground
seemingly down for the count after the
last attack he suffered from giutaro
even one of his arms is cut off so
things look really bad and like the many
pillars who fell to gyutaro before him
it seems like tengen has lost not only
is he this hurt he's also been poisoned
for quite some time at this point and
gyutaro seems to believe that he's even
dead yutaro ends up telling tanjo that
tengen was weak and determination was
his only strength thinking that the
pillar was down for the count however
after tundra takes up some of yootaro's
time and ends up being in trouble tengen
suddenly appears and comes to the rescue
holding one of his blades in his mouth
zoro style it turns out gyutero was
wrong tengen wasn't dead he actually
forced his own heart to stop to keep the
poison from circulating this not only
let him survive for longer it also
opened the possibility for this surprise
attack we're told and this builds off
the music and sound theme that
accompanies tangent that tangent has
analyzed combat maneuvers to the point
where he can read them like sheets of
music it just takes time he converts the
rhythm of the enemy's attacks into sound
so every fight becomes a song he hears
repeated phrases and can attack between
beats and during the rests dancing with
his opponent but the poison has him at
his limit so he can't deliver the final
blow that's pretty cool to know about
tengen and so in general he would do
better in prolonged fights because he
has a better sense of the opponent's
rhythms but in this case the poison has
complicated things and tundra has to be
the one to finish gyutaro off
nonetheless tengen is very impressive
and now that he has a grasp on his
opponent's rhythm he manages to deflect
most of his attacks with one arm to give
to the shock
does end up slicing through one of
tengen's eyes and again tengen is such a
boss it doesn't even slow him down now
that i think about it that's another
thing he has in common with zoro not
making a big deal out of insanely
painful injuries eventually thanks to
tengen's help tundra manages to cut off
kyotaro's head as zaito and enosuke do
the same with daki which is the key for
beating these two so they stop
regenerating yutaro's body unleashes one
more surprise an explosion of blood
blades antagonist prackly at death's
door when the dust settles his tongue
stops working from the poison and he
looks horrible but luckily nezuko's
flames succeed in curing him of the
poison he lost an eye and an arm but
he's alive unlike the other pillars who
face gyutaro albeit he did have a lot of
help from tanjiro nezuko inosuke zenitsu
and his wives during chapter 97 there's
also a pretty hilarious bittersweet
moment when tangent and his wives look
exhausted and unimpressed saying six
that's the lowest of the upper ranks and
quote it's obviously good that they beat
an upper moon but also disheartening at
the same time because it was so hard and
they took so much damage just to beat
the weakest upper moon this realization
probably plays a role in tangan's
decision to retire although even before
the actual fight there was mention of
retiring when they beat an upper moon
anyways it's just lucky in this case
that they ended up confronting 6 rather
than akaza or someone stronger sun emmy
the snake pillar doesn't help matters
when he shows up and says and i quote
what are you going to do about losing
your hand and eye in a fight with mere
upper six end quote clearly among the
pillars tangent's feat wasn't as
impressive as we might have thought it
was and tangent knows this and even says
his plan is to retire and that there's
no way he can fight anymore he does tell
the angered tsunami though that tundra
and the others have grown strong so
they'll be able to make up for his loss
there's no doubt about it tengen was
amazing and he did as well as he could
he was brave cool and pretty strong so i
want to give him full props however it's
clear that among the pillars as he
himself acknowledges he's no genius some
people might think i'm hitting on him in
the comments but it's not an insult to
his character you can be a weaker
character and still be an awesome
character and among the current
generation of pillars tangent is among
the weaker ones as we know gyoume is the
strongest and muichiro the other pillar
tangent singled out as being especially
talented beat upper moon 5 by himself
without losing an arm or eye at only 14
years old while tangent got as hurt as
he did from upper moon 6 a weaker upper
moon while he also had a lot of help to
boot it seems this generation of pillars
is especially talented though since as
we mentioned upper moon 6 beat many
pillars from the past but i'd say he
wouldn't have fared so well against this
generation and tengen said as much when
he said that gyutaro was lucky if he
thought that tangent was especially
talented because that meant he
conveniently avoided all the stronger
pillars up to that point when then goku
died and tengen got the news he remarked
and i quote even then goku lost to an
upper rank moon end quote suggesting
that then goku was another pillar that
tangent viewed as being stronger than
himself after tengen's retirement
pillars also start awakening to their
demon slayer marks which is kind of like
going super saiyan for demon slayers
because of that any gap between the
other pillars and tangent would only be
increased in my all 9 pillars ranked
from weak as the strongest video link in
the description i placed tangent only
ahead of shinobu shinobu is the
physically weakest of the pillars and
cannot even cut off a demon's head so
must resort to poisoning that being said
shinobu also has her own strengths and
she definitely used her poisons
amazingly throughout the series and
helped take down upper moon too but it
did cost her her life and it did also
require a lot of help from kanou and
inosuke as well at the end of the day
the point i want to make is that all the
pillars are actually amazing and tengen
played his role well and saved our main
characters multiple times during the
entertainment district arc despite not
being the strongest pillar he was a
great entertaining character and i liked
the fact that there was someone who
actually knew where to draw the line and
retired before he died in battle the
dude put in the work and then retired to
enjoy life with his beautiful wives
while occasionally popping back into the
story here and there and who can blame
him for that i'd probably do the exact
same thing but that is it for this one i
hope you enjoyed it and if you do enjoy
these kinds of videos definitely check
out my demonstrator playlist where i
have a similar video for almost every
pillar and many other hype characters as
well if you did enjoy this video you
know what to do channel the yorichi
within and smash that like button with
no mercy smashing is your ichi energy
and passing is muzon energy we all know
this so you know what to do and as i
said if we can hit 4 000 likes i repeat
4 000 color changing thumbs i will get
started on the next video asap just let
me know if you'd prefer that i cover
mitsuri or shinobu next in the comments
and vote for your favorites if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and while you wait
for the next demonstrator video to come
out feel free to check out my giant and
growing demonstrator playlist that
includes videos about all the hashira
demon moons and much more link to that
is in the description and i especially
want to thank the patron squad over on
patreon and here on youtube who helped
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost i want to thank the patron
of legend the one acknowledged by lord
wigo himself alpha sigma and are the
one-tier patrons the ones who stay on
top all clans ingrata but they have the
alger hinokami and water the toasted chi
the spike corey mcgowan dylan isadore
spidey life tinnell tungsten tarkis
baked buddhist cody hebert and monkey d
quilly and our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only gilgamesh the red-haired
raven angel cruz brethuen de aura very
gucci alicia actor bonnie parks joanne
garcia ted no ted fatboy games and soul
ride slice and dice thank you all so
much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com anime uproar and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patronly discord where we talk about
anime life and of course thank memes so
check out patreon.com anime upload link
in the description if you are interested
you can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed so yeah you
can support more content that way if you
prefer and whichever way you support us
you will get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you